for today so far we're still inside this
range this is your high this is your low
you can see the price comes to fill at
least the 50 of this week
sorry for the line maybe this better
then you see it got filled then price
bounces super highs remember that there
is always liquidity above the previous
High and the previous low all right
because that's where the stop losses are
going to be inside the range okay so uh
with this little week they hit a lot of
stop losses do not super highs then go
again to the bottom of range sweep the
lows they are basically doing the same
thing here
and now we are inside this range all
right so now the question is what can we
expect I'm gonna tell you my opinion of
course it's not Financial advice but
what I think is that you know if you put
together
one and one that's two okay what I mean
is that you know you've had a lot of
volatility here
on Monday on Tuesday so you've had here
let me show you
um what is my tool here right you fat
here a seven and a half percent drop on
Monday and then on Tuesday you have a
eight percent pump that's a lot of
volatility and you still have to think
that next week we have CPI data and also
F4 music meeting with the interest rate
decision and of course the Bots plot so
it's going to have all of volatility
next week okay that's what I'm thinking
that if we've already had a lot of
volatility at the start of the week and
next week we're expecting a lot of
volatility too the most likely a
scenario in my opinion is that we
established some kind of sideways move
here okay
probably until next week then next week
depending on the news announcements on
what they say the market is going to
react to it all right so that's what I'm
thinking I think that date is not going
to be much uh volatility now until
probably next week
I might be wrong well that's my opinion
at the moment okay
um that means that scalpers and day
traders who still are gonna see trading
opportunities every day until then but
maybe swing Traders have to wait a bit
long okay that's what I'm thinking uh
now let's try to make sense of what it
could happen today so far what I can say
in the four hour time frame is that you
know if you check the candle bodies you
can see that we are really
inside this you know it's a hundred
dollars range so it's quite tight at the
moment the price action is quite tight
you can see a lot of weeks to downside
also to the website and that means that
you know they are trying to build a
position so we are gonna try to go into
lower time frame and see what they might
be doing all right let's go into the one
hour time frame in the one hour time
frame uh not much going on to be honest
I mean I can see a week here
let me check for you this week here
it hasn't been to fill the 50 okay
because the 50 is really in this one
here
and you can see that they haven't hit it
yet all right so they're leaving weeks
behind
um to be honest for example you can see
this one here
just go filled this one is getting
filled with this new candle right but
you still have this one here that it
hasn't got filled that's at twenty six
thousand two hundred Zone okay so that's
the first thing
that I see watch to do so you have a
quick here okay you have that week you
have that week
and of course to me the most important
level here is that you go and Equity
pool here
okay
so let me Mark it for you the level
that's 26 820.
and to the downside let's try to find
some liquidity pools I would say that
you have this one here
okay
and also you have
this one here the it hasn't been
retraced for you okay so let me Mark
those levels for you
so you can see at the right of the chart
okay so you go to the downside twenty
six thousand seventy four and twenty six
thousand one hundred forty nine and to
the upside twenty six thousand eight
hundred twenty
so those are the zones that we can see
in the chart now what zone are they
gonna move to all right so let's go to
the 15 minutes time frame lower time
frame even okay
I mean what I can see here so far
is that all the moves to the downside
have been
buy very large scandals check out this
large Scandal okay another large candle
here another let's candle here
so that is telling me
that the market making is probably
dumped in price very aggressively to
build some longs
that's what I'm thinking that today I'm
gonna favor higher prices I think today
we might see twenty six thousand eight
hundred twenty that's what I want to say
and once you figure out you know what
level or what zone they're gonna move
price to you have to think what song
they can hate first to open a position
okay so that's what I'm thinking that
maybe
I mean the New York section is starting
right now if we see you know a stop hunt
first towards this level here
hang on I don't like the color orange
let me do it blue please that's the
color of my liquidity pools have to be
blue
let me get them
come on there you go okay it does better
isn't it so what I'm thinking is that if
they're gonna move price towards 26 120
now I have to think what Sunday can move
price to first so I can open a position
okay first thing one hour time frame
50ma
you can see that we are right below it
it's been testing and resistance for one
two three four five six times
in this one okay that's a clear
resistance at the moment that's the main
resistance right now the 50 main the one
hour time frame so if they pump price
straight away then the setup that you're
looking for is this
push then hopefully you can see a
retrace towards the 50ma in the one hour
time frame that's when you can open
along
and Target this Zone here this liquidity
pull to the opposite okay so that's one
setup that's kind of like the safe play
all right of course you are gonna lose
some appreciation in price
but that's not a problem because you are
you know longing
at support in principle all right now
um if we see
uh a drop first okay that we can open a
position
in my opinion that would be sorry
that would be these two levels over here
okay this should Equity pulls here I
would like to see a drop here first
I don't know if it's going to be towards
this liquid pool or to the next but I
mean it's only like
a hundred dollars difference okay one of
these two liquidity pools at least and
then price hopefully bouncing hard
towards 26 120.
we're in Hublot capital and you can see
that the liquidity at least in the short
term is to the upside okay check out
this one here between twenty eight
thousand two hundred
and 20 28 000 okay there is a lot of
liquidity here but also between twenty
seven thousand six hundred fifty and
twenty seven thousand five hundred if
you put together these two zones that's
a lot of liquidity okay so
um again I don't know if we are gonna
hit these zones this week uh I'm
thinking no to be honest I'm thinking
that if there is a chance that we go
towards this Zone it should be next week
because I'm not expecting much
volatility this week okay I might be
wrong with this but that's why my good
instinct is telling me what I still
think is that you know we've seen a lot
of volatility Monday and Tuesday we're
gonna have a lot of volatility next week
so let the markets to cool off first
before we move aggressively again okay
so maybe these songs if next week is you
know quite bullish with news
announcements and uh we see a poom then
these two zones are gonna be your
targets before I finish the video I want
to remind you that you can trade
immediate it's an exchange that doesn't
require kyc and if you register with the
link in the description you're gonna get
five dollars bonus for free also any
deposits between two hundred dollars and
a thousand dollars get uh ten percent
payback so that means if you for example
deposit let's say four hundred dollars
they're gonna get forty dollars for free
all right uh ten percent payback and
also well if you deposit a bigger amount
you get bigger rewards of course and
anybody that deposits at least a hundred
dollars is going to participate in the
next giveaways for the trading course
for free last week we did a giveaway of
10 winners for the trading course in
July and we'll do new ones soon so
that's pretty much everything I want to
say guys thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon